ho scoperto ragazzi che esistono le
miniere di gta cioè tu puoi far saltare
in aria la porta quei pugni magari non
con le bombe per forza avere dai bomba
voglio vedere cosa c'è dentro noi sarà
figata incredibile permesso anche la già
totalmente figo o la torcere la pista è
bellissima sembra abilitazioni the
walking dead dove che puoi andare ma è
tanto lunga sta facendo e so più alla
moto3 espandiamo una moto perché non so
quanto dura sta roba
che sfiga son chiuse cielo tutto sto
casino e poi se non chiudeva bene è
stato bello però sono emozionato mi
cagherà addosso a farlo dal vivo però
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo tornati
su un nuovo episodio di gta per i
ragazzi oggi ho provato a caricare
questo che vedete per poi che una mappa
strada tom watson avere comunque a parte
quello buongiorno a parte che sarebbero
it on salt and è a posto
sono io pelato praticamente chiuso
questa roba è una mappa ragazzi che
racchiude un sacco di istant di cose che
si possono fare
proviamoci triage allora non l'ho ancora
provato era talmente è così che nascono
le macchine non l'avevo mai capito è
talmente era figata ragazzi che avrei
dovuto provarla un sacco di volte e
stranissime come se vedesse me in questa
persona qui ma non sono io c'è un sacco
di roba e io non ho praticamente fatto
niente voluto tenerla tutta presto video
perché è tutta da scoprire
quindi 3 2 1 il gioco è crashato ai
ragazzi son tornato nel punto di prima
proviamoci detto non ho ancora visto una
donna che figata
non ho ancora visto niente finalmente il
primo salto
si comincia magari speriamo la radio
mentre siamo in alto si no porca vacca
volta che marco il caso pretesto parla
radio allora non ho idea di dove stiamo
andando
sembra tutto molto divertente piacere e
mi sono salvato per miracolo va bene e
di non so bene fare questi la madonna
domanda quanto tempo ci ho messo per
fare sta mappa è incredibile è veramente
pazzesca e una mappa incredibile porca
vacca occhio e caschi
non ho ben capito dove se c'è un finale
o qualcosa però sembra veramente [ __ ]
ecco nel caso a un finale non è
sicuramente questo ma quindi non è una
mappa ad ostacoli c'è chi se ne frega se
la finisci non l'importante che ti
diverti questo l'importante è vero
teoricamente non so dove sta andando
aiuto
e infatti non andava da nessuna parte
porca vacca però quasi parcheggiato
allora ragazzi proviamo con una macchina
un pelino un po più con gli attributi
non so neanche come si attiva sta roba
fortunatamente la madonna
il fatto che senza attiva orco lo schifo
in terra aiuto o scherzavo solo dato
troppo veloce
mammamia troppo forte ho preso una
macchina troppo efficiente
riproviamo strobo quello attivo solo se
c'è necessità
mamma mia ragazzi veramente incredibile
allora che parte andiamo io andrei a
destra perché a destra mi sembra un
attimino più complicata la faccenda
proviamoci qua perfetto madonna come
tengo bene la guida dei ragazzi nessuno
mag
devo fare un giro della morte
ok ricordatemi non farlo più grazie
porca vacca sono storto ma è così
difficile fare ste robe ragazzi che giro
che non è così sempre
c'è porca vacca di prendere un giro
tutto strano amen
vai abbiamo fatto la prima curva il che
non è male tanto sicuro che stanno nella
mappa lo stacco di chi se ne frega
mettiamoli esistono i turbo e io siamo
già questo c'è turbo più turbo un casino
vai amico mio bagno o la madonna che è
successo a si fermato era solo per
andare più veloci in quel punto da e
amico mai madonna che casino lavado no
vabbè ragazzi stampe incredibile la cosa
più bella che abbia mai visto
c'è una scritta ciao qualcuno si è
abbonato al canale ciao amico non t'ho
visto
vi ricordo che gli abbonati compaiono
anche nei video normali miglior cavalca
è brutta roba ho fatto ok bene bello
dove stiamo andando ragazze aiuto c'è
poi dove stiamo andando
fatemi capire mi proviamo a fare il giro
della morte era non so se questo credo
sia non so se come sono sicuro sia
questo sai città di tanta roba strappa
di incredibile telescopio lui la madonna
ok l'ho presa veramente storto ma vabbé
non fa niente e difficilissimo da vedere
madonna è sì casino per ragazzi
veramente un casino ve lo assicuro
uoro buono buono ma non meno perfetto
questa mi è piaciuta ancora bravissimo
ce l'ho fatta ho preso il giro poteva
evitare di dirlo anche se vedete voi il
giro della morte enorme quello che
voglio fare già da un ora lo voglio fare
prima che è difficilissimo non era di
cooperazione
se guardate quanta roba sport naturista
mappa c'è veramente enorme e geniale
come ho fatta non giocarla questa doveva
essere la prima dovevo farla come prima
cavolo
va bene siamo arrivati prima vedere se
qua stato mortalmente il checkpoint sono
arrivati qua se riesco a fare una roba
fatta bene perfetto più perfetto
perfetto buono buono buono buonissimo
deve arrivare mamma mia
ok forse ci atterro preciso forse non è
vero un provino davvero importante lo
spazio è bene ok allora quello ci credo
ci si arrivi dico altro popolo gigante
ci proviamo a iamm in house e bellissima
sta macchina ragazzi si chiama non è in
bilico non so come si chiamava chiama
non importa veramente [ __ ] ok qua è
difficile qua devo fare lo slalom fare
attenzione perché sono casco che un
piacere allora piano piano piano piano
piano poi veramente un casino raga
ok molto bene sembra di fare le montagne
russe solo che non devo stare fermo devo
guidare io perfetta porca vacca
secondo me se finisco sto video vi danno
anche la patente in omaggio cavolo che
mappa splendida e veramente belli e la
più bella che abbia mai fatto ragazzi
vai vai vai vai io passati sopra
bellissimo sono fatta oggi tre devono
alla madonna
ogni volta che tiro il turbo va
velocissimo e veramente il feaga sta
macchina lato è la mia preferita per
adesso o che madonna quanto è grosso
mi piace sta frase di trame
vai fa bene casino mi sa che un attimino
fuori controllo la situazione ragazzi
eccolo eccolo è una montagna russa
gigante ci siamo allora l'inizio no
cavoli questo fosse una roba nuova va
bene alla prima della sinistra era era
quello io se non so se è stato attirato
dall'inizio praticamente ormai che
possono atterrare benissimo anni anni
ecco per sotterrare da dio a rafa non so
dove andare sinceramente destro sinistro
esso sisters si destra destra era meglio
la sinistra ma non fa niente
andiamo a destra destra piano che yamen
ora una volta che siamo qua non so cosa
c'è non ho idea
e l'ultima parte che mi rimane ragazzi e
questa riesca a fare qualcosa piano anno
giusto ma ok io penso di dover andare lì
sotto
molto bene molto bene molto bene vai
fratello vai non sono ancora andato di
qua è fantastico ora deve entrare nel
tubo orca vacca piano piano piano piano
benissimo qua c'è un tubo gigantelli mo
vai il turbo lo uso solo né quando vede
le pendenze assurde tipo questa infatti
qua era decisamente utile da usare se
riuscisse a tenere la macchina
beh però il bello che hanno messo degli
stop automatici dopo di stop di
automaticamente fighissimo allora
ragazzi che ci abbiamo un'altra salita
incredibile che non prenderei col turbo
perché rischia di andare troppo avanti
esattamente
però adesso sì all hotel odetto
incredibile
l'ho detto l'ho fatto e lo sbagliato
deficiente un deficit e potendo poter
andare anche sulla rampa di sinistra
però l'ho già fatta prima quindi no ok
qua dentro non so cosa ci sia ragazzi
proviamoci by molto bene una mega ramp
ha di nuovo
non vedo dove sta andando non vedo addio
mio addio mio 2 che siamo leoni qua o
finirà prima o poi sta roba
mammamia contaminata stamattina quando
normalmente dove si trova veramente figo
dove c'entra qualcosa ma mi sa che è
finito qua perché qua e là dove dove ero
arrivato anche prima quindi niente
ragazzi questa è la finale definitivo
meno che non ci sia qualcosa qui sotto
ma no quindi a posto
raga è stata la mappa bellissima mi è
piaciuta tantissimo ma tant'è la più
bella fino adesso veramente parte gli
scherzi speriamo di parcheggiare
perfetto parcheggio trovato quei ragazzi
se però vi sia piaciuto è stato molto
divertito divertente ma soprattutto cosa
sta facendo la polizia secondo un tizio
ha fatto più danni alla polizia anche
altri ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
come associazione momento mi piace anche
per i soci al gomito tutta la
descrizione iscrivetevi al canale e ci
vediamo come sempre al prossimo video da
ragazzi
[Musica]